people absolutely love your show my
assistant goes on and on and on about
your show and occasionally I'll try and
say how do you think our what do you
think of our show last night and she
cuts me up and says we're not talking
about that and then we go back to
talking about your show yes you have a
bona fide uh smash on your hands you got
to be thrilled
yeah I mean you know
the reaction is uh all thrown off I'm
Thunderstruck but here's the interesting
thing
you guys play morally reprehensible
characters
and and and you yes yes
please I'm here to attack you
I wanted to slow you into a false sense
of security with a standing ovation now
the attack we've done we've made some
mistakes yeah no no no no no
the show the show is hilariously funny
but it is interesting that it almost
couldn't exist in a different era you
guys have made the characters have you
not but they're they're pretty
reprehensible people who never seem to
learn their lesson is that right yeah no
it's true I wonder like how it would
have been received in the 50s if people
would just you know be like in front of
their television it's like
we're holding a very dark mirror up to
society yes what we're doing with the
show yeah it's really just an awful
reflection of of society's fault
exactly watching but you know what's
funny it's like I look look at the show
and you see there is an evolution of of
the characters wouldn't you say that the
characters have evolved I'm not saying
necessarily for the better for example
Glenn more of a d Evolution yeah yeah
Glenn always creepy now a sociopath on
the show Dennis
yes but I guess you're saying your
character the character the character
but but kind of creepy but it almost
seems like you're you're going out of
your way
to make the character I think sociopath
is fair I think that's part of the fun I
think it's part of the fun is seeing how
far you can push and have it still be
funny that's part of the challenge and
as we get this deep into the show we're
nine seasons in I think just I think
we're now at the point where we're like
how far are people gonna really go with
this before they start you know Banning
the show and throwing up and just hating
and just hating us so you're trying to
think and and and Charlie your character
started out not too bright and now
you're going out of it's it's like it
almost seems like you're on a mission to
see how dumb can I make this person is
that is that right is that a fair
assessment I think like season two we
were like oh you know it's kind of funny
if he's dumb and then he just he kind of
just stayed dumb I don't think he's got
gotten more Dumber
I just know when I when back years ago
when I was a Sit Right on The Simpsons
we had so much fun making Homer and we
kept pushing to make him dumber and
dumber and dumber and then the bosses
running the show would come in and say
you you've gone too far we had him once
gets mad his own brain got mad at him
and walked out and slammed a door
I feel like you guys are having a lot of
fun trying to see how many boundaries
you can put that's the problem we are
the bosses so there is no boss to come
in and tell us you're going too far it's
us that's it and we've noticed that the
Dumber we make them the more doors open
creatively so right
so our brains just walk right out the
door wide open you know